he started his business with $20,000 at
his wife and his friend helped him raise
he's the first mainline China
entrepreneur to be featured on the cover
of Forbes magazine he's the richest man
in China and the 18th richest man in the
world with an estimated fortune of
twenty nine point seven billion dollars
he's Jack Ma founder of Alibaba calm and
here are his 10 rules for success when I
graduate from universities and before
you know for three years I tried fill in
the universities so I apply jobs for 30
times got rejected
I went for a police listen no you're not
good I went to either even the KFC when
KFC come to China come to I say 2024
people went for the job 23 people
accepted I was known to a guy and we
went to four please five people full of
them accepted I was the only guard in
aristocracy been turned down
rejected oh yeah everybody's alive
because what do you think your core
competence is I'll call its culture it's
not the technology I think technology is
a to it the core components of our
companies we have 225 would grow from 18
people to now 20,000 young people and we
focus a lot on the valley in a mission
and making sure the character everybody
work for helping others instead how
instead of you know just to make you
money people don't like it so many
people I talked to at that time for all
they play they say this is the stupidest
idea you have ever gotten but I say I
don't read the stupid Club as long as
people use it now we have 800 million
people using this alley pay I learned a
lot of things from from movies I learned
how to make a speech from the movie code
bodyguard Whitney Houston when she sinks
the Suns I look at her wow that's the
way that you make a speaker because I
never know how to make speech because
I'm not actor but when I saw the movie I
say wow
if you sing from your heart if you sing
naturally if you hear yourself so I I
realize and I learn a lot from the
movies you know even learn from the
Godfather's and they're my favorite
movies the forests the gum you know
these are these are the things that
learned so much then I will discuss
about the the muse the inspiration so we
got from movies what kinds of business
ideas have you said no to I'm saying no
to a lot of ideas because as a CEO I
have to say no to opportunities because
if I say yes I probably got a five
thousand opportunities every day but
where are the years or know everything
based on the mission that will helping
is doing business easier if it's on that
will consider if our somebody come you
say can you we won't have does it to you
will make a lot of money I'm not
interested why did you call it Alibaba
Alibaba well when I started I think
Internet is below but we should have a
global name and a name that interesting
like that that time the best the name is
Yahoo right I think I can I've been
thinking for many days suddenly Alibaba
is a good name so I I was happened to
being sent San Francisco today and I
didn't have a launch and the richest can
I ask him do you know that Alibaba she
said yes I do what is Alibaba she said
Open Sesame
good so I wear down the street ask about
10 20 people they own know about Alibaba
40 sieves and Open Sesame
and I think this is a good name and
start with a whatever you talk about
Alibaba is on top we believe the cocom
very different from the Wall Street we'd
be the custom number one in point number
two share whenever customer one employee
to share everything yeah are we again
this is my religion you know if you it's
the custom that pay us the money it's
the employees that drive the innovation
it's the shareholder a shareholder
always say you know I don't remember the
day before we IPO and a lot of people
say I cannot give out the shares we were
long-term shareholders but when the
crisis came these guys long as soon as
they run away my people stayed custom
stay people start complaining some
people complain some stuff people's have
to change themselves change others where
the opportunities is where the
complaints are where the towel
where's
thank you guys for watching the question
of the day for you is I want to know
what kind of rejection you've had to
overcome in your life and in your
business if you've had to overcome a lot
of rejection you have a special story to
share I'd love to hear from you if you
want to leave a comment below I made
this video on Jack mob because Jeff
Liang asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
leave a comment let me know what you
think and I'll see what I can do and of
course if you like this video and you
want to see more don't forget to
subscribe to the newsletter in the
channel thank you for watching continue
to believe have an amazing day and I
hope you'll start your day again with me
tomorrow with another inspirational
video
one one supermodels one love this volume
you you have the most important work
ever if you had to think of one word
that's most important to you or that
sums you up or that would be like a
little beacon pay believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details